all right I'll be at Northwestern
University tonight talking about the
left's war on on reality their efforts
to redefine reality by redefining life
marriage and gender so we'll be talking
about that tonight hope to see you there
now before we get into today's show
let's first discuss wise food you know
that I think it was Shakespeare maybe
Jesus who said hope for the best but
prepare for the worst or maybe it was
neither of them but either way it's it's
true preparedness is key you never know
when you're gonna be in an emergency it
could be a tornado a flood an earthquake
power outage even if you lose your job
you could find yourself in a situation
fortunately though wise company is here
to save the day and they take an
innovative approach in providing
dependable simple and affordable
freeze-dried food for emergency
preparedness and outdoor use wise
company meals are designed to protect
your most valuable asset which is your
family so whether you're so busy that
you barely have time to cook or you're
in an emergency situation wise emergency
food can save the day all you need is
four cups of water and it doesn't even
need to be hot you take the the contents
of the pouch you pour them into the
water you stir you cover and that's it
in 15 minutes you're ready with a meal
so this week my listeners can get any
wise emergency or outdoor food products
at an extra 25 percent off the lowest
market price at wise food storage calm
if you enter Walsh at checkout or by
calling eight five five four seven five
three oh eight nine plus if that's not
good enough for you shipping is also
free Wise has a 90 day no questions
asked return policy so there's no risk
in taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today that's
wide wise food storage comm wise food
storage comm promo code Walsh to get any
wise emergency or outdoor food product
at an extra 25% off and free shipping
all right
The New Yorker shared this week in
editorial written by Anne anti-natal
list
philosopher named David Benatar no
relation to Pat Benatar I think maybe
there is I have no idea
the title of the piece is the case for
not being born
okay now this article was actually
originally published a little while ago
but it's making the rounds again online
and it's worth talking about because it
articulates an especially toxic way of
thinking that I think is also
increasingly prevalent in our society
today antinatalism if you've never heard
the the the phrase before and it's by
only recently came across it myself
antinatalism is what it sounds like it's
a movement against birth so similar and
related to the pro-abortion movement or
maybe it's you might call it a logical
conclusion of the pro-abortion movement
anti-natal ist's think that no child
should ever be born ever again that's
their position that no one should ever
be born and they I think generally will
say that this should be a voluntary
decision that we make to stop having
babies although there are some who will
say that the government should also
potentially enforce that that policy and
some governments do it force that policy
now some of the people who believe in
this philosophy have organized into this
is a real thing
the voluntary human extinction movement
which is not a joke it's that really
exists it's a group that as the name
suggests believes that humans should
choose to go extinct now at least
there's the voluntary part of it we
should be concerned if though if they
ever lose if they ever lose the V you
know and it just becomes the human
extinction movement heme then that's
that's that's not you're good but right
now it is voluntary a guy by the name of
les unite which I assume is probably a
pseudonym but who knows he started the
group back in the in the 90s I think if
you're curious about them they're there
website has an FAQ section and here's
the first frequently asked question that
they answer it says what is the
voluntary human extinction movement okay
and the answer is it's a movement not
organization it's a movement advanced by
people who care about life on planet
Earth we're not just a bunch of they
care about life they just think it
should be extinct we're not just a bunch
of misanthropes and antisocial misfits
taking morbid delight whatever disaster
strikes humans they say they're not just
that so they are that also but just not
only that nothing could be farther from
the truth voluntary human extinction is
the humanitarian alternative to human
disasters it's humanitarian belief that
humans shouldn't exist
we don't carry on about how the human
race has shown itself to be a greedy
amoral parasite on the once healthy face
of this planet that type of negativity
offers no solution to the inexorable
horrors which human activity is causing
rather the movement presents an
encouraging alternative to the callous
exploitation and wholesale destruction
of Earth's ecology as a voluntary human
extinction movement volunteers know the
hopeful alternative to the extinction of
millions of species of planets of plants
and animals is the voluntary extinction
of one species Homo sapiens us very
encouraging you know it's just it's
encouraging so we're just we're gonna go
extinct and we can all be encouraged by
that possibility each time another one
of us decides to not add another one of
us to the burgeoning billions already
squatting on this ravaged planet another
ray of hope shines through the gloom
whenever when every human chooses to
stop breeding Earth's biosphere will be
allowed to return to its former glory
and all remaining creatures will be free
to live died evolved and will perhaps
pass away as so many of nature's
experiments have done throughout the
eons it's going to take all of us so I
don't know I'm sold I don't know about
you I say let's go extinct I think it
sounds like a great idea now that you
mention it so that's one reason for
being an anti NATO list because we are
allegedly destroying the earth and
that's why I say that this is an
increasingly prevalent philosophy there
are a lot of people who feel this way
now most anti NATO lists won't call
themselves that probably I've never even
heard the phrase or know what it means
and most certainly aren't going to join
up with the voluntary human extinction
movement but
anyone who goes on about overpopulation
and says that we we have to solve
overpopulation solve it you know how do
you solve it there's only one way to
solve it people that say that you know
we need to stop having so many kids so
as to save the planet anyone who holds
that position is by definition and
anti-nato list and a lot of people in
the West hold that position a lot of us
do overpopulation by the way is is a is
a prominent myth and I emphasize myth it
is a myth the earth is not overpopulated
the earth really cannot be over pub
there is no max capacity for the earth
and anyone who thinks thinks that there
were earth is overpopulated well what do
you when did we go from populated to
overpopulated what what do you think the
capacity is and where did you come up
with that number if there is a max
capacity for the earth for human beings
we are we are not anywhere close to it
and we'll never get close to it because
human birth rates are declining already
now the population is still growing and
it will continue to grow for a few more
decades but the birth rate is going down
there people are having fewer and fewer
kids so we're not anywhere close to if
there is a max capacity we're not
anywhere close to it we're never gonna
be close to it because right now only a
tiny fraction of the Earth's land
surface is populated half of the earth
is still wilderness half of the earth is
still is still an untamed wilderness
right now today and and then you have a
lot of very spread out role rural areas
and so on in fact you could fit the
entire population of the world into
Texas you could not only fit us all into
Texas but we could all have our own our
own town house and a little plot of land
we wouldn't have a ton of space because
we're all living in Texas but we could
all fit in Texas with a town house and
anti yard so
which would leave the whole rest of the
globe completely unpopulated now have
you ever noticed that whenever whenever
you read an article about overpopulation
it's always accompanied by a picture of
Manhattan or Hong Kong or LA or you know
a place like that but those are
relatively small areas where millions of
people have chosen to cram themselves
into and yeah Manhattan does have a max
capacity at max capacity that's much
larger than you think because we started
living vertically right unless we start
building skyscrapers rather than a
living horizontally we live vertically
now and that's how we can crab all these
people into a small space but you know
if you leave the city and you travel
across the country which I think it's
nope now I don't have statistics in
front of me but I'm willing to bet that
the majority of people who believe in
overpopulation live in cities I'm
willing to bet that and these are
probably a lot of people who have never
even been anywhere else they've only
ever been in cities if you actually
drive across the country what you're
gonna notice is that there are vast
swaths of inhabitable but uninhabited
land vast swaths of it same thing in
China Russia any other large country you
can think of what you're gonna find is
you're gonna have cities where a lot of
people crammed in but then there's a lot
of land where no one's living they could
live there but no one is so the earth is
not overconfident there is a problem
with overconsumption and and waste
that's a problem but that has nothing to
do with population if if you're buying
more food than you need and then you end
up cleaning out your fridge once a week
and throwing out a bunch of food that's
gone bad because you didn't eat it well
you're not doing that because of the
population that's just a choice that you
made and that's an individual decision
and yeah we should encourage people to
make better decisions but that doesn't
mean that we need fewer people what we
need is we need more
responsible people and it's good to
advocate for responsibility but to claim
that well instead of being responsible
let's just have fewer people that
doesn't make any sense
and you can't you can't say that greater
population numbers lead to more people
starving because there's not enough food
to go around or whatever well you know
5,000 years ago there were 10 or 15
million people living on the planet and
a far greater percentage of those people
would have been destitute by our
standards far greater percentage well
what changed technology innovation we
have figured out better ways to feed
people and provide for people and that
has allowed our population to grow now
it's not perfect there are still people
who are destitute but we are much better
today at feeding people and producing
food and doing all that than we were
5,000 years ago or a thousand years ago
now so the overpopulation thing is is
just a myth but this article in The New
Yorker about David Bennett our takes a
different approach because you have
people who say that we should stop
having babies because we're killing the
planet it's overpopulated but then
there's this from The New Yorker it says
David Bennett are maybe the world's most
pessimistic philosopher and anti-nato
list he believes that life is so bad so
painful that human beings should stop
having children for reasons of
compassion you know in a book he writes
while good people go to great lengths to
spare their children from suffering few
of them seem to notice that the one and
only guaranteed way to prevent all the
suffering of their children is not to
bring those children into existence in
the first place in Benatar's view
reproducing is intrinsically cruel and
irresponsible not just because a
horrible fate can befall anyone but
because life itself is permeated by
badness in part for this reason he
thinks that the world would be a better
place if sentient life disappeared
altogether sounds like a maybe the title
of an emo song in like 2002 permeated by
badness and yeah this is this is really
nothing new this is what
emo bands have been saying this for you
know decades now this is basically a
Dashboard Confessional song that this
guy is putting into book form the idea
here is that life itself is so miserable
so painful that it's better to spare
people the suffering now that may sound
like an extreme view and it is but it's
not a fringe view or at least it's not
as fringe as you think
once again this is this is kind of
common this is basically nihilism and
there are a lot of nihilist today in the
world people who believe that life is
essentially meaningless and if life is
meaningless then pain and suffering is
meaningless and if pain and suffering is
meaningless and life incorporates so
much of both then it isn't a stretch to
say well maybe life is a net negative in
the end maybe life is a is a curse
it seems to me certainly that if there
is no God which these people if you're
an anti-natal list or a nihilist or
whatever then you you'll almost
certainly don't believe in God if
there's no God than human consciousness
at the very least is a disastrous
mistake committed by nature this New
Yorker piece quotes a line from Matthew
McConaughey's character and true
detective Russ Cole when he says human
consciousness is a tragic misstep in
evolution and without God yeah that
seems probably true because we not only
live meaningless and short lives in that
case but we are doomed to be aware of
the meaninglessness and brevity of our
existence we have to live always with
the awareness that we are hurdling
headlong into non-existence and I think
that's what what Bennett R is saying
you're saying it's not worth it there's
no point but I think the big flaw in the
idea that we need to stop having babies
to save the planet or we need to stop
having babies to spare our future babies
from the pain of existence is that
consciousness is the only thing capable
of perceiving value in the first place
so the thing
makes our our planets special is that it
is our planet that's what makes it
special we are conscious and aware and
able to cherish it without that our
planet is just one among trillions and
there are probably trillions of planets
in the universe and if if if there's no
human life on this planet no one around
to cherish it and love it and you know
appreciate it
then who really cares and then it's just
it's just like I said one of trillions
then who let it be destroyed why does
our planet matter I would say that our
planet matters because we're here
because we live on it it's our home it
doesn't make sense to say that we should
go extinct so that we don't destroy our
home because if we're if we are extinct
then it's not our home anymore if it's
not our home anymore that it's just one
truck one Rock among trillions of rocks
spinning around space and I don't see
how it has any special value in that
case yeah it has other life on it but
that other life is not capable of
perceiving the value of the earth or of
itself
a horse can't love the earth and a horse
can't love horses only people can love
horses and the planet so it's kind of
the old if a tree falls in the forest
thing if the earth is beautiful but no
one is around to perceive and appreciate
its beauty then why does its beauty
matter I mean how can you even call it
beautiful I guess it still is but
there's no one around who can notice it
now you might say that
even without people the earth would
still matter its beauty would still
matter because it glorifies God but
again these anti-natal lists don't
believe in God so from their perspective
human life dies off and really there's
no one left so far as we know in the
whole universe to appreciate the
universe's beauty it
the thing that makes the earth so
special is because as far as we know it
is the only planet in the universe that
has that plays host to conscious life or
any kind of life as far as we know it's
what makes it so special you get rid of
that conscious life then what's the
point yeah now it's like if you took the
Mona Lisa and you you threw it into the
ocean well yeah then it's the Mona Lisa
will still be beautiful on the sea floor
while it's sitting down there but you
may as well have destroyed it because no
one is going to be able to see and
appreciate its beauty the fish might see
it but the fish don't care to them it's
just a just a rock so it would be little
solace to say well yeah I threw it into
the ocean but it's still there you know
it's down there somewhere being
beautiful well great but what's the
point of a beauty that no one who is
capable of appreciating beauty will ever
experience and it's kind of the same
thing with Benatar's argument that if
that life is you know people say well
life is so miserable so why curse people
with it well first of all speak for
yourself second of all it doesn't make
sense to say that non-existence is
somehow better than life even a painful
life because a word like better assumes
value but non-existence can have no
value so to say that something is better
than another thing you must be saying
that the better thing has more value but
if but non-existence by definition has
no value so it cannot be better than
anything it's just nothing and as
nothing it can't be better than
something even if that something is is
pain so there's just a logical problem
there there's a logical problem with all
these ways of thinking that we're gonna
somehow you know save our our home by
making it so that it's not our home
anymore because we're all dead just
doesn't make any sense but it's like
I've been saying it's a it's a lot of
people sort of think this way and it's
it's a very troubling sign because what
I see really is Western culture just
giving up on itself you have Western
culture is giving up on itself giving up
on life giving up on existence and that
is a certainly a troubling sign for the
future all right Bill Nye fake scientist
he popped up on John John Oliver's show
this this past weekend and here's what
he did here I've got an experiment for
you safety glasses on by the end of this
century for missions keep rising the
average temperature on earth could go up
another four to eight degrees what I'm
saying is the planets on fire there are
a lot of things we could do to put it
out are any of them free no of course
not nothing's free you idiots grow the
up you're not children anymore I didn't
mind explaining photosynthesis to you
when you were 12 but you're adults now
and this is an actual crisis got it
safety glasses off mother so there you
go Bill Nye he's so relatable when he
curses isn't he so he said he just he
gets me as a millennial has anyone I'm
trying to think why I posed this
question yesterday online has anyone
ever gone so far from one end of the
likability spectrum to the other because
you think back to the 90s Bill Nye was
you know people my generation we grew up
with him and he was a charming kind of
nerdy fake scientist guy on TV and and
now he's just a insufferable partisan
hack has anyone and I said that in a few
people
Justin well oj simpson bill cosby ok
well that's that's valid so maybe
another way of putting it is
has anyone ever traveled so far from one
extreme end of the likability spectrum
to the other without committing a
violent crime and I think probably no
one has done it as effectively as Bill
Nye going from so likable to so
intensely unlikable that's what's
happened with Bill Nye but it it it
shows you what the left has done with
science I think it's kind of it's it's
sort of perfect then Bill Nye has become
the lefts scientist he is their
scientist of note and the guy that they
go to to make a scientific point when
he's not even as he's not a real
scientist he's as he pointed out in the
video he taught you know eight-year-olds
about photosynthesis back in 1992 that's
those are his scientific credentials he
doesn't really have any others I think
he got a he got a bachelor's in
mechanical engineering or something
that's his whole that's his side he got
a bachelor's in mechanical engineering
and then he taught eight-year-olds about
photosynthesis and that's this whole
scientific resume but it's it's very
telling that the left has taken him and
he is now their voice of science because
that's what the left has done with
science they've turned it into a into
this into something that's certainly
whatever else you want to say about it
it's not scientific it's more of a brand
science is now a brand and Bill Nye is
the is the mascot for that brand
speaking of brands Chips Ahoy
decided to celebrate Mother's Day Chips
Ahoy
you know the company that with the
really bad cookies really in had
inedible cookies and I'm not just saying
that because of this what I'm about to
show you but who the especially the the
hard cookies your trip to hawaii-i-i who
does anyone eat those how could I don't
what I don't understand is how could you
ever eat
a hard prepackaged chocolate-chip cookie
if you've ever had a homemade chocolate
chip cookie in your life how could you
possibly eat that other stuff when you
have that comparison in mind that's what
I don't understand but that aside this
is how they decided to celebrate
Mother's Day Jana what we celebrating
today Mother's Day and I am so thankful
to have a mother like mine who supports
me through all my craziness and loves on
me and Barney Chips Ahoy cookies chewy
the original everything under the Sun my
mom knows I love my cookie so get those
cookies and what's the sweet gesture for
you to do to your mama your real mama
your drag mama whichever mama somebody
whoever take care of you whoever you
feel or consider your mama
yesterday today get them a cookie or two
a peg bottom auto-ship some boys in the
world I don't know but get some milk
get some milk - you came by to cook
without some milk honey get those
cookies it's Mother's Day it's time to
celebrate love all that cookies get them
and if you don't how you gonna celebrate
Mother's Day it's the new chocolate yeah
okay so now Chips Ahoy after releasing
that video they have then been then gone
on to taunt the people who are mad
because they had a drag queen selling
their cookies and no but see this is
again this is something the left does
where they do something stupid and
bizarre and we all say that's stupid and
bizarre they say why you're so mad stop
freaking out snowflakes
now we're not mad we're just confused
why do you need a drag queen to sell
your cookies it's a really weird bizarre
confusing dumb thing that's all we're
saying so it's not about being mad I
really don't care how Chips Ahoy sells
cookies but why do you need to if you
want to sell cookies why do you need to
put drag queens into it you notice this
with
with that this is what they're doing
they incorporate drag queens into
everything now they're really trying to
get this drag queen thing going and I've
asked this question a million times I'll
ask it now a million and one times I
need someone to explain to me I just
give me an explanation how is it that a
guy wearing a Native American headdress
appropriates Native American culture but
that dude in that video doing this
ridiculous embarrassing impression of a
woman does not appropriate womanhood
that's what I want to know how is it
that you can appropriate Native American
culture black culture Asian culture a
white person opens up a Chinese food
restaurant he appropriates Nathan Berg
okay
that's appropriation how is that thing
that you did that act that you just
witnessed there how is that not in
appropriation of womanhood that's all I
want to know that's what I don't
understand all right let's go to emails
Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt wall
show at gmail.com this is from Jay says
mister Walsh I recently asked a good
friend of mine several questions about
religion she's a believer I am NOT she
informs me that she has sent religious
questions to you and you have answered
some of them on your daily show what she
listens to every day she thought that if
I set my questions directly to your
email you might answer them on your show
the main question I have is why did God
create the universe the only answer I
can find on the Internet is that he /she
created the universe so that human
beings can worship him /her why would an
all-powerful all-knowing all benevolent
Supreme Being need or even want worship
this does not seem reasonable to me my
other two questions I raised with your
listeners are much simpler than the one
above first why do people have different
blood types it would seem that if
everyone had the same blood type would
be easier and faster to cure someone
who's an eatable blood transfusion the
last question is why do we only have one
heart there are animals that have two
hearts we have two eyes two ears two
kidneys two lungs but only one heart
says our heart is the only important
body part or is the most important body
part sorry
not the only important in order to exist
it would seem that we should have two of
those the last question the last two
questions are similar to the website
that asks the question why won't God
heal amputees these questions may seem
trivial however I know that if I had the
ability to create a human being without
any limitation on my ability to do so
the extra heart is a no-brainer I'm just
trying to find some common-sense answers
to what I consider reasonable questions
I and almost all non non-believers would
easily become believers if we were
showing solid proof that there is a God
they are reasonable questions yeah
certainly not not unreasonable let me if
you don't mind for this for our purposes
now I will hone in on one of those
questions and maybe I'll answer the way
I could answer the other ones in a
follow-up segment of the show so why did
God create the universe you said that's
the main question all right and then
this bit about why does he want worship
the way that I would answer that
question and any time you're dealing
with a why question with God it's you're
not going to be able to get a perfect
answer because the first answer is I'm
not God so I can't give you his
motivations I mean I can't even give you
I can't even tell you for sure the
motivations of another mortal human
being I can't tell you for sure why
anyone did anything that they did
because that requires me to be able to
read their mind which I can't do as I
certainly can't do it for God I can't
even do it for my own kids but what we
can do is arrive at some reasonable
conclusions based on our own logical
thinking and based on what they told us
and you know we can patch that together
and come up with maybe some ideas to
what the motivation was so my answer
would be that God created the universe
out of an act of love now the Christian
belief is that God is all loving as you
I think mentioned in your email
well a love right love seeks an object
love is directed towards something or
someone and so it makes sense that God
out of this act of love if it is perfect
love then it is creative love is love
that creates its own object of its love
it creates something to love and so
that's the way that I look at and that's
then that's the answer also that I get
from Scripture that's the answer I get
from 2,000 years of Christian teaching
and Christian philosophy is that God
created the universe out of an act of
love and he created us in order to love
us now in terms of worship
why does God want to be worshipped I
would I would put it a different way
it's more that we as human beings have a
need to worship and I think even as an
atheist you would you would see that
right we we haven't we have a need to
look up to someone or something to
admire something to have a kind of model
to strive to emulate something to strive
towards and I think you see that all
throughout human history and you see it
in the hearts of all human beings and I
think as an atheist you have to ask
yourself well how did that come about if
we are nothing but the product of blind
evolution then where did this capacity
not just capacity but need to worship
how what evolutionary advantage is there
is is there to that and how is it that
unthinking matter could develop this
desire need for something like worship
it just it seems illogical that
unthinking inanimate matter could create
that so I don't know I think you have
your own question to answer
which is how did
get this needed desire for worship where
does the concept of worship even come
from in a in a godless universe my
answer is that it is a fundamental
desire part of the human condition and
so it we're going to worship something
you might worship money your worship
your career you might worship your
people around you your worship
celebrities people worship a lot of
things but what God is saying is none of
those things are appropriate objects for
worship because none of those things are
perfect none of those things are
all-powerful none of those things
created you what God is saying is I am
all those things so I am the proper
direction for your worship to be to go
towards I am the proper object of your
worship so I think that's what it's
about it's about it's just about the
proper ordering of this innate desire
that we have so I'll tell you what why
don't you I just posed a question to you
and email me back in an answer to that
question I'm very curious to see what
your answer will be and then we can
continue this discussion from there this
is from Michael says mr. Walsh why is my
generation so ungrateful we live in
literally the best time in history yet
all we do is complain about the
patriarchy corporate overload or
overlords and so on what's wrong with
people that they can't see how great
life is yeah well this is one of the
problems when you it's just we're
talking about you the human condition so
it goes back here's another thing with
the human condition is that you take for
granted we just naturally take for
granted the situation that we are born
into it's just so it's hard for us we
are born into this very comfortable
existence and we can acknowledge
intellectually that there are people in
the world who don't have such an
existence and we could acknowledge that
if we look back through history there
was a time when almost nobody lived such
an
existence we can acknowledge that we
know that it's true but we can't really
appreciate it to us it's it's abstract
it's just a fact that's hovering out
there until we've experienced it now
someone who falls on hard times and
lives a destitute impoverished life for
a time and then climbs back out of that
well now they can appreciate more of
their comfort but if you've never
experienced that it's hard to appreciate
it and I think that's the answer and
that's one of the reasons why I am such
an advocate for people you know leaving
rather than staying home with your
family until you're 27 or 28 and then
you get you know you're financially
stable then you go out and and and you
get married or whatever go out on your
own before that and really on your own
without your parents bankrolling it
leave the house when you're 18 19 20 and
live on your own and make some
sacrifices and live a less comfortable
life take care of yourself learn how to
do that and it's gonna make you more
grateful for the comforts of life and
that I think among all the other
advantages you know when I say that
about how well we should leave you know
leave the home and people will say to me
that yeah but historically you'll find
that you have people would stay home
with their families until they got
married and that that's the way that
that it worked historically all
throughout human history and that's true
but the difference is that you know back
in the day a man would stay home in his
parents house until he got married but
but you know but he was working the farm
he was doing something it was not an
easy comfortable ID he wasn't just
living at home and his parents are
taking care of him when he was 23 no he
was he was out work in the fields at the
age of 20 at the age of 12 he was out
there doing he was doing - he's
contributing to the family was words
that was a it was a hard tough existence
and he was helping to keep the family
going until he went out and started his
own family
that's completely different there are
still places in the world where that's
the way it works that's completely
different from what we have today which
is you just stay home and your parents
take care of you like you're a baby
until you're 28 and then you go out and
they're still paying your bills and
everything and that's completely
different that is what we have today are
people who are infantilized and among
all the problems with that I think you
have this lack of of gratitude where
people have never made never had to
sacrifice they've never had to go
without that never really had to
struggle they've never had to really
worry about where's their next meal
gonna come from how are they gonna pay
their bills never had those worries and
so they end up being ungrateful brats
great question though both of them were
great questions so I thank you for that
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching everybody Godspeed today on the
Ben Shapiro show the Trump
administration doubles down on the
Chinese trade war and Democrats defend
anti-semitism as usual that's today on
the bench Shapiro show